[Music]
def
booty to
[Music]
do
e
4 p
[Music]
gj
j
[Music]
beitr e 4
celebee
[Music]
blana
web
tee
n ame
me
car
ran
deenice
eeme
ana
ban ban
ana b
me
yeah
yeah eaa nuuuuuu
[music]
do
paddy
5 minutes walk
checked
war
[music]
yeah yeah yeah
padi increase [music] more car car yeah yeah yeah  Yeah yeah
yeah war
war
ha
[music]
4 minutes
me
[music]
paddy
2 good
[music]
ne
yeahyeah yeah yeah jan yeah yeah yeah
j
car
web
hey
[music]
Apollo
[music]  ]
dj
Favorite th jan
[Music]
re
ed.
[Music]
Garden
car
Yeah Yeah Yeah Mainstay Yeah Yeah Yeah tanteememale dee Yeah Yeah Yeah tee me Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
[Music]
as
well
Dubbo
[Applause]  ]
[Music]
elcar
goome ah ah ah
[Music]
[Applause]
dj
tee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music] Hmm
me
[Music]
[Music]  ]
[Applause]
[Music]
n
voodoo rank
jan
[Music] N
Moody
[Music]
voodoo
web
th
[Music]
Hmm
voodoo f Hmm
[Music]
voodoo
ten
me
[Music]
Hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
Tokyo Game Show 2021  Watch
online  Good evening everyone,
I will send you a Capcom program from here
.
[Music]
Good evening everyone.
Thank you for watching today
.
This time, tgs 2021 Capcom Online
Program Monster Hunter
Spotlight, so I mainly provide
information on the Monster Hunter series.
I would like to deliver it with Mr. Tsujimoto, the producer of Monster Hunter series, with Usami acting as the moderator.
Yes, thank you for your cooperation with the team.
Today,
there is information on Monster Hunter Rise's break, so please
take a look at it at the end.
Since time is limited,
I would like to proceed immediately.
First of all, I will deliver
the latest information and contents of the popular Monster Hunter Rice with Mr. Tsujimoto and Mr.
Ichinose, the director of Monster Hunter Rice.
I think I want to do
it, but in Monster Hunter Rise,
the first one is
a monster hunter story,
and the second one is a wolf. The third one is a street
.
The fourth one is a collaboration content with Rockman Eleven
.  We have delivered it, but today
I would like to send you the 5th information. First of all,
please see this video.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music
] Hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
Prosperity  That's why it has
been decided to collaborate with
the
returning
Makaimura, which is now on sale.  In addition
to making it look like Arthur when you wear this layered equipment, we
have prepared a special child such as a change in spear and a change in the production when clearing the quest.
The bgm of the returning Makaimura
will be played, so I think that you can play in a different atmosphere than usual
.
Recently, the collaboration will end with this 5th bullet. It should be noted that the event that can be downloaded
for free by connecting to the Internet even after the October update
Regular delivery of quests, all special news  It
's a quest where you can get production materials for rewards and equipment,
so please try it. Also,
new paid download contents will be
released. Please check it out as
new contents that make your hunting life more enjoyable will
appear
.
In addition, today
we will deliver one special collaboration
information here. We
have decided to collaborate with Monster Hunter Rise and Sega, who celebrated the 30th anniversary of this year. We
collaborated with Sonic once when Monster Hunter 4 g
.  There are times, but we are working
hard to make it a fun collaboration different from the previous one, so please
wait a little longer for more information
.
Here is another communication information.
The download version of Monster Hunter Rice is for a period.
It will be a limited sale price If you
have not played yet, please take this opportunity to
play
Monster Hunter Rise game The latest
information is over, but
those who are wondering how this title was made
I wonder if there is,
yes, from here on, I
'd like to talk to everyone about the setting of Monster Hunter Rise
and so on.
I'd like to make it possible to talk about things under development for a while
. This time, I've been telling everyone
that the theme is ad as the theme
, but I've been telling everyone about it as Rise.
Monsters are getting a lot of attention, so
I've
been telling everyone that it's a new and new
thing, but there is a place where it's a Japanese youkai or a motif.
Yes, youkai or Kaigensho.
I'm making good things with
the motif,
but I think it's because I don't want to explain a little about what
kind of youkai motif the drone is.  The holiday is a video.
That Kawado uses it as a motif,
but it's damaged. Well,
Rio Leus store.  There is an illustration of the world where Su is flying a fireball from the sky, but
I also add a
little image to the motif of the movie, and
also Tigalex and Kironex.
Even if Tigalex, a youkai called
Hayamabiko, runs, there is a thing that is made by comparing it to the voice of Yamabiko
.  Even if you
bring 3 selections after hell, even if you enter
into arbitration where other monsters are interacting,
the pass
seems to give judgment. I know that there is a little made in the motif
.  The old and old kettle mass production
minister full full
that is effective
against
ghosts of Nargakuruga, and the pop ring that was being received by Shinko.
However
,
I actually made it by applying it to such youkai, so if
you can see and know the scene,
you may be able to polish 5 cars,
so please take a look.
I think it's quite a room like
this, but when I was applying various things to Germany, it's hard to say that this
monster
is gradually disappearing from youkai songs, isn't it
?  I didn't just come to a youkai,
I broke it towards the end.
Let's walk Nu. Comet Halley, ah, old
books, or
something suspicious.
For example,
Tiro and other monsters.  There are things like
that you can see it from that perspective, new discoveries,
and tomorrow's theme of the game,
Tyranno
taber, so I'd like to ask everyone to look at it from that perspective.
I got a goddess
, but it's 3 interesting. Well, this time
, even with that
manipulative treatment, I'm reading it with the manipulative treatment.
Maybe it's
really creating an atmosphere
I'm sorry, I'm sorry
, so I've
talked about that various things about the door, but in fact,
this time as well, it's after this, even in the game, I'm
playing Biwa.
I'm sure everyone will be able to see the performance by the qualification examination later,
so
I hope you enjoyed it as well, so I'd like
to talk about the next
one, but before that,
there was one announcement
today.  I'm talking about the first public release, but
the update at the end of October
I
think that there will be
a new additional
voice player.  Yoshimasa Hosoya and Riho Sugiyama
have been appointed, and the number of boys has a lot of individuality
.
Since I tried to make a machine inside, the
voice distribution member matching captor
recipe is also scheduled to be released so that it
can be reproduced on the character creation screen.You can also play as an Empi character.  Actually, I
'd like to wait for that information until the delivery, so it's
pretty good that the 4 of that voice
is in the form of a paid sale called that sale,
but it's quite a
good attempt.  It's an interesting attempt, isn't it? What
kind of character is it just a little bit? It
's better to have the character played by
Mr.
Hosoya's vote.
Ta ah ah ah
sand pya
line
Nadaman
Hosoya It's a male character, and Sugiyama-san should do two things mikko. Body
Zue Jeweler
sore
Iwaya Step
Fefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefemura
r Every Hejunes by Nah
Yumon-sama me
Getz at 10,000
Come on
chain  Way eg e
Actually, these two people seemed to be familiar with the party, and in
such a place, it was quite
a dialogue like never before in each situation, and
I recorded a lot
of things like that, so I can enjoy it.
I think it
would be nice if you could ask me a little bit about
it.
Rice is fine. The
oil and sugar villagers are also quite various. Actually, the
settings that I can't talk about in the game are
actually oppressive.  It's interesting,
isn't it? Well,
I think I should do it so much if I have the opportunity.
Because I make a saying, but I said that
I had a little trouble, I
made various things such as ordering and
sold it-I could not implement it in the
game.
One of them is Yomogi-chan,
and even if I make a few things with Chisaki, the buns are
n't delicious
and I can't understand unless I explain them in such words
.
I'm not here, so I told the person in charge that there aren't any of them, so I
made a little bit of that kind of setting
and tried to implement it, but Miha
Nati is still lying down.
However, I heard that
it came out with game-like specifications and I'm feeling
immersive now that it's selling a little bit, but I
think that a lot of in-game files will come out,
but in fact I can
meet that.  It's called motion capture
. People act a and capture the movements in the
game, but
it's often called motion capture,
but that's the vow that humans grow
naturally.  There is a
little video of it this time,
so it's not quite difficult with this, isn't
it? It's a lot of white
.
Various people and various roads  I'm
going to take various motions by using tools,
but in addition to that scene that I just saw
, there are also
a things that I'm taking with Airou's movement motion capture
.
It might be interesting to have a look during the game and see
how it's recorded, so it
might be interesting to see it
while
thinking about it.  That's about a,
but if you're a child, it's been
about 4 years since the sound development of is itself, and it's
finally possible to deliver it to everyone in March
.  All of
these staff are
really pleased to play it. Also, I
hope there is an opportunity to tell you about interesting development stories. I hope I can
tell you again.
Mr. Tsujimoto  1 Thank you very much for talking about the back side of horse production development
.
Assessment Monster Hunter Rise
probably incorporates Japanese elements into music.
Next title Before going to the latest information, its
symbolic performance singing
Various eights
We have specially prepared a music live corner that you can enjoy with. We
also have a bonus track of Fume shipped today,
so please enjoy
it.
[Music]
ni
[Applause]
[Music]
dare
[  Music]
goo
Wool
[Music]
Ah ah ah I
had
goo
ah ah ah ah ah
me
[Applause]
[Music]
The votes of the Hajinmon are now the same as they used to
be.
Wow
[Music]
Central exchange
Hmm, I'm crazy every day er
Ah,
I'm
good
[Music]
r
Hey Peace-kun
[Laughs]
dj Ah ah ah
Yeah that country
Wow
r 2
Ah ah ah
coo
goo
Cheek-like child
Guard Hmm
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah ah
ah
[music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ah ah ah yeah yeah yeah
[applause]
[music]
depain
[applause]
[music]
ah ah ah
[Music]
[Applause]
Ah ah ah
open
[Music]
Avon
can
[Music]
san
[  Music]
How was it?
It was played in Thai.
Kamura's Breath Rock version will
be distributed as in-game download content from December, so please enjoy it at the game party
the other day.  We will deliver the latest information on
Monster Hunter Rise Can Break just announced
. Thank you, Mr. Tsujimoto.
Yes, from here on, we
have selected the director of this work to deliver information on 3
breaks.
Let's introduce
ourselves Yes, I'm in charge of the director of Monster Hunter Rise's break, taking over from Ichinose. I
'm only Yoshi Suzuki.
Thank you for your cooperation today.
This development is
after the release of Monster Hunter Rise.  In the update,
this is the one in the west of the city,
who has been in charge
of it as a breaker. And at the same time
, Suzuki is promoting the policy
of 3 breaks.
I would like to introduce you to Suzuki, but before that
, I would like to say a few words from Monster Hunter Rise director Ichinose
. Thank
you so much for playing Monster Hunter Rise since it was released in March of this year.
The development members
have seen how everyone is enjoying the game
and the message to the work, and
I am full of gratitude
.
Thank you for your continued support of Monster Hunter Rise and Monster Hunter Rise, which I will introduce today.
Please see this video again.
[Music]
First, it will be the basic information of this work.
Monster Hunter Rise Break is a
book content with high signs of Monster Hunter Rise
. Many elements that can further enjoy Monster Hunter Rise have been added, such as the
story field starting from a new base
, Monsuta Akshon, and
the appearance of Master Rank as a quest rank.
If you are
currently playing Monster Hunter Rise,
you can purchase 3 breaks as additional content
. You can
enjoy various elements added from the brakes by clearing the meeting place quest Hoshinana Raijin.
The
subtitle 3 Break is a visual image in
which sunlight shines into various areas in your field.
8 I
added it from the story image of this work. Next, I
will introduce the contents of the game.
First, I will explain about the world view.
3 Is Break a base for Monster Hunter Rise
? We will start from outside the village
and head for a new research base
.
A
new field will appear in San Break. It is a field with
a place like a delayed leak and a field
with a crimson sky spreading at night and a forested atmosphere
.
Next, the monster that appeared in the video
This is the main monster of this work  The
name is Sakuginryu Beerze.
This is an old dragon type monster. This is the end of what I
can tell you this time,
but I hope to provide more information about what kind of monster Merce is
.
And today, I used the video of the series monster that will be resurrected in 3 breaks.
Please see this video.
Akibun Gizami is
a monster that first appeared through Monster Hunter. A
large shell species that carries the skull of a huge monster.  With
sharp and long scissors, it attacks prey with
a powerful blade that can easily gouge the bedrock of a hard volcano.
There are some monsters coming,
so please look forward to future information.
That's all for the latest information on the games that can be played
.
Finally, Monster Hunter Rice's
break
is scheduled to be released around the summer of 2022, and the price is undecided
. Please wait for the follow-up report.
It will be information on the steam version of Monster Hunter Rise
First of all, please see this promotion video
[Music]
Ah ah ah
, so everyone waiting for the steam version has been waiting
for the release  Was
decided on Thursday, January 13,
2022. Reservations will start shortly after the program airs,
so please make a reservation.
Please check the official website scheduled to be released today for details on the release of
oct14 and the schedule for subsequent updates. We also plan to deliver Experience 1 on Thursday,
oct14. Please look forward to it
.
Furthermore, it is
the title update information that is being ruined by the popular Monster Hunter streets
.
This work is set in the world of the Monster Hunter season,
and it becomes a
monster hunter who grows monsters and coexists.
It is
rpg that you can experience the world of music to your heart's content.
Since its release on the 9th after Hyena,
we have continued to make free updates so that everyone can enjoy it for a long
time.
I think it's Ginmine Gum, staring at the soul of love,
and a giraffe foot has been added together.
It seems that
Momutaro was a face that changed its state and was responsive as if to reproduce the delusional world.
That person is
still continuing the title update, isn't it?
We have compiled the video including the update,
so please have a look there first.
Me
[Music]
[Applause]
Ahhhhh In
the 4th title update,
Rex rare species will be added together
, and you will be able to play the quest to fight with Tabs.
In the week following the delivery of
, not only will the race using black smoke
be added, but also the nest of the old dragon species will be added to the joint battle exploration.
It will be done so please enjoy it. It's
easy to get the eggs of the old dragon species that are on hold
. Yes, I'm
really looking forward to it.
And there are still more title updates,
right? Yes,
the 5th title update is the most difficult to create.
Miraboreas will be added many times
more. In addition, 2 Nams will be added to the joint battle search,
so I think it will be easier to obtain the eggs of 2 Monster Hunter, so
it was a secret for the high difficulty joint battle
quest.  The monster was
Miraboreas, but of course it's a high-difficulty quest
, so it's strong, but
it's a content that aims to subdue with a smaller number of turns,
so please try it by all
means.
The week after the high-difficulty beauty labo Diaz was delivered,
Rio Rei and the rare
beauty Reus rare species will be added as sound patterns
.
There are many additional quests, so
I'm really looking forward
to the delivery schedule.
Please look forward to the delivery date
.
And if you haven't played yet,
please take this opportunity to play with it. The
trial version is currently being delivered, so please give it a try
.
Monster Hunter Rise event
quest and steam version released
Monster Hunter stories
2 free titler plate
Furthermore, Monster Hunter Life's
break and I can't take my eyes off the version series anymore.
Well then, after this,
it will be a news corner that will deliver the latest information on the school.
I will say goodbye to Mr. Kajimoto here.
Thank you, Mr. Moto, thank you.
Well, I understand from the box, and now it's the information corner
. First of all, I will deliver from the import related information
.
In
the Street Fighter 5
Champion Edition, which is a huge breakthrough, 45
characters will appear. The
new character loop that will carry the future will
be re-signed in November.
It's my car
league.
Ajimari is the 2018 league original
team formation. The
color and the grand final were won
by Mr. Yamata, led by Itabashi Zangiev.
The grand final of the second season is the
Son Scarlet Association.  The last runner-up was
the confrontation of the other, and it
was the Magoskar line that decided to win the final round and the two-handed carpet ko
.
[Applause]
Don't win with medical care Lolo's championship Denmark
will introduce the cello rare system in 21 years this year
Expand the hope from 6 teams so far a The
number of games is also from 30 students to 56 and 8
power  Introducing the first spot of interest
Fake Prophecy
Wood Wari and Making Road Street
Fighter Fluffy and Pressure Shun
Shun-kun That's Saying Butter
Shiraki Gaming
Nagoya Oja Poller
6 plus Pa Union and Child
dec 4
Website First Team 32 People  One of the fierce fighters fighting for the
best in Japan by Tally's
Project b 2021 Making it in October-
Next is the best deals
Capcom's popular titles are on
sale for a limited time to commemorate the Tokyo Game Show 2021  So please check if
there are any titles that you missed the opportunity to play.
Tgs 2021 Parenthesis
Online Program Monster Hunter
Spotlight We have delivered it, but it's
about time to
finish here.
Thank you for watching
[Music]
Yeah Yeah Yeah Ah Ah Ah
Ah Ah Ah
[Music]